[Music]
but the next playlist was off-roading
addict a chance to race Into the Wild
[Applause]
driving off-road gives you an
opportunity to carve your own path to
explore the open expanse
the island becomes your playground total
freedom becomes your Creed
[Applause]
fine
Mulligan
let's just rewind that one
[Music]
[Applause]
four by fours pickups quads you're given
every chance to go off the beaten path
foreign
[Music]
is freedom improvisation but the next
playlist is all about the competition
they named the Motorsports playlist this
one is for the pros
[Music]
foreign
Motorsports is built around racing to
the top the thrill of competing but it's
also about strategic choices decision
making under pressure
destroyed
there is no better feeling than
triumphing with your team and what some
consider the Apex of Motorsports
[Music]
making the call when to go for the pit
stop checking on your Rivals it gets
intense
[Music]
felt good to be the champion but then I
got to go old school
whoa vintage garage a playlist for the
true car aficionado
I love you
with these cars it's not just about the
look or the Nostalgia
it's how these things Drive how they
feel how they steer it was quite a
challenge in the best way possible
outside of some collector car park when
would you ever get a chance to take
these venerable Legends for a spin
That's The Power of vintage garage
a taste of an age where there was no
Nitro to boost you and no GPS to guide
you
strangely comforted
[Music]
so out with the old and in with the new
they say the next playlist is legendary
[Music]
Lamborghini a playlist to truly
experience the iconic the trail racing
I'm running out of adjectives here
[Music]
as soon as you saw that Lamborghini logo
you knew what this playlist was gonna be
some of the most recognizable car
designs in existence at your disposal
thank you
[Music]
there's nothing quite like some of these
cars it's like a speed race through the
story of Lamborghini one of power and
innovation
[Music]
foreign
the full roster of these Legends was a
rare privilege a privilege motorfest
graciously gave me
and now it's your turn
[Music]
goodness
like what you saw well those were just
the tip of the iceberg but we've got to
go step by step follow me